[Música]
[Aplausos]
fracaso miedo al fracaso
es algo que yo mismo he ido
experimentando todo este rato mientras
que estaba a punto de tocarme
es a un montón de cosas pensadas porque
me sentía tan nervioso pensaba porque
temblaban las piernas y me imaginaba
muchas cosas
imaginaba que cuando salga de ahí iba a
pararme en esa escalera y me iba a caer
y va a salir una foto en que diga danger
boniface y el fracaso
y todos tenemos miedo al fracaso voy a
contarles un poco de mi historia
cuando tenía 15 años me encanta a mí me
encanta el fútbol y el niño más todavía
tanto que quería ser profesional
mi papá había sido un ex futbolista
frustrado jugaba en san agustín pero su
mamá le dijo que no podía jugar fútbol
porque era un deporte para tontos porque
eran 22 personas creciendo una sola
pelota
no pudo ser futbolista se metió la
fuerza aérea y obviamente tenía las
expectativas en mí y yo sí quería jugar
fútbol me metía la prueba a una prueba
en la uv y pase y jugaba para menores en
la u luego pase a la san martín ya
parece que tenía futuro en el fútbol
cappa estaba muy emocionado y me mete a
estudiar al euro idiomas alemán
porque quería mandar a jugar a alemania
decían que ya como somos acá más
recursos lo podemos llevar más rápido es
mucho mejor ir allá a jugar aprendido
unas cuantas palabras en alemán
pero en el colegio en cuarto de
secundaria me encuentro una chica que me
movía el piso
a una chica que era de las populares yo
en el grupo de los pagos
y era del grupo de los pagos tanto que
no iba a ir a la fiesta de pre promoción
y esta chica popular se queda sin pareja
de promoción de promoción entonces dije
esta es mi oportunidad la voy a invitar
la invitó y resulta que las cosas van
bien y somos enamorados
esa chica que me movía el piso y me
gusta mucho
estoy con ella la pasó bien tenemos un
año y mi papá me dice daniel es tiempo
de que te vayas a alemany a jugar
dejar el fútbol
a casa un primer fracaso
estoy con esta chica un año y medio
medio año más después de haber dejado el
fútbol y viene ya el tema profesional
voy a estudiar la idea que estudiar mis
papás me decían bueno ya dejaste el
fútbol métete una carrera más amplia
administración
la administración será me meto a
estudiar administración entró segundo
puesto parece que había algo prometedor
ahí a los seis meses me salgo de la
universidad
fracaso más
y decidió meterme a comunicaciones me
gusta las relaciones personales puedo
hablar bien quizás serán las
comunicaciones
hoy un año en comunicaciones en la upc
y resulta que me voy un viaje a la
sierra del perú a hacer una ayuda social
a oruro un pueblo muy alto en puno
y me di cuenta de la necesidad en el
país
me di cuenta que el anhelo más profundo
que tenía y que todos tienen también es
dejar alguna huella aquí en la vida
en ese momento era niño era chiquillo
tenía 18 años y dije la única manera de
dejar una huella en la vida es dedicarme
a las personas dejé la carrera de
comunicaciones
para ser sacerdote
definición del fracaso según el filólogo
policarpo petrozzi el fracaso viene de
dos términos el prefijo frank que
significa entre o en el medio de algo y
en la otra palabra que significa cuásar
y que significa romper
la palabra significa romper por la mitad
eso significa el fracaso de hecho don
quijote de la mancha' lo usaba para
hablar de las armaduras como quería
fracasar armaduras quería romperlas por
la mitad la rae
trae esta definición hoy y la usa de
hecho desde los navíos que fracasaban
contra los escollos y hoy en día si
ustedes buscan la definición de la rae
fracasar es romper en mil pedazos es
decir cuando un plan fracasa es que se
rompe en mil pedazos
años de estudios de filosofía y teología
me había dedicado a ayudar a los demás
vivían en comunidad me faltaban tres
años para ser sacerdote
la salida es el sacerdote
y a la cosa se pone un poco más
complicada cinco años de mi vida salía
de ser sacerdote
mis amigos habían terminado la
universidad estaban en trabajos muy
buenos
la chica esa que me movía el piso tenía
enamorado
la paz me reciben de brazos abiertos
pero obviamente yo
la casa
y aquí viene un punto bien importante y
es que no se trata de que fracases que
se dicen a ustedes mismos cuando
fracasan
cuando siento yo esa experiencia de ser
fracasado siento decepción siento
angustia inseguridad pero que se dicen
que me digo a mí mismo en este momento
yo me dije danielle bonifaz tú eres
capaz de terminar nada
esa frase la categoría después de muchos
años en este momento no tenía idea
solamente sentía muchas cosas es capaz
de terminar nada administración
comunicaciones con esta chica ser
sacerdote nada futbolista nada
tiene la otra teoría la teoría de la
estupidez
y pasa cuando fracasas te sientes
inseguro decepcionado pero hay tres
posibles caminos
o ignoras que fracasas y vives en las
estrellas
way
o ves el fracaso directamente dices no
es fracasado y te vuelves más estúpido
todavía
o lo aceptas bueno al comienzo cuando yo
había dejado de ser sacerdote
vengo a toda la onda más como
superficial o na vamos a vivir la vida y
empiezo a vivir mi vida ignorando de que
realmente es fracasado
retomo la universidad dejé la guerra de
comunicaciones un año la vuelvo a
retomar y en ese camino es que me topo
de nuevo con esta chica que me gusta y
que me mueve el piso otra vez
y estaba como enamorado bueno eso no fue
impedimento para
volver a retomar y volvimos a estar y
esta chica me aterrizó porque esa chica
ya había terminado la universidad estaba
en un trabajo muy bueno una
incorporación y yo recibí en la
universidad entonces me empieza a comer
por dentro algo que digo porque yo estoy
tan atrás mis amigos ella yo no podía y
ya no ya había dejado la época de la
ignorancia y ahora simplemente me topado
todo el tiempo con mis fracasos que
empiezo hacer tengo que ganarme la vida
todos mis amigos ganan plata entonces me
meto a hacer vip los grabamos esos que
van al matrimonio que internos ya yo era
el que manejaba la lista venía en la
gente de la cola y en el matrimonio
pérdida de asistencia pero era y aquí
viene la época la estupides porque es la
época en la que tú no aceptas y vives
esclavo de lo que el resto te va a decir
o va a pensar de ti tanto así que una
vez venía una amiga en la en la cola y
yo estaba y enseñando y no quería que me
vea y tiró las lista y me voy y me
escondo
era una época tontísima tontísima y era
tan tonta tan tonta que yo mismo me
engañe
o la mujer que me movía el piso
porque porque no quería que ella sienta
esto que yo sentía esta incapacidad de
terminar algo
pasa el tiempo en la que no me salía
nada bien la universidad era mediocre
los trabajos que tenía trabajaba en una
agencia como community manager empecé a
aprender y resulta que llegó un día
después de una fiesta en la noche y mi
mamá estaba sentada en la cocina ella
siempre ha sido mi coach
y me acuerdo claramente lo que me dijo
cuando apenas llegué a la cocina y me
dijo quién eres
te reconozco
fue ese es el momento en el que tú te
chocas con la pared después es mucho
tiempo y me eché a dar
darme al piso no saber qué hacer
un momento bien importante y esto es la
primera enseñanza del fracaso es que el
fracaso te hace volver a ti mismo y te
hace reflexionar
cuando te hace reflexionar están las
tres opciones que le digo esa
conversación con mi mamá me hizo aceptar
aceptar que estaba parado en un lugar y
que sobre esto no podía pasar nada más
porque lo peor que te puede pasar
después de para cazar es fracasar
ya está en el hoyo y entonces empiezan a
florecer cosas cuando ya aceptas que has
fracasado empieza a florecer la
creatividad
creo que una vez que entran hacia
ustedes mismos y se aceptan ya dejan de
pensar en ustedes mismos y empiezan a
ver los problemas que hay afuera y
empiezan a intentar a solucionar esos
problemas que ven se me ocurrieron miles
de ideas estando en la universidad una
de ellas era judía porque es algo común
huber con estas personas que están
lavando carros para que puedan acercarse
a ellos a través de una aplicación
geolocalizada y empezar a soñar un
montón de ideas hasta que me junto con
unos amigos
era un amigo que venía de viaje de
australia con ahorros en dólares
y él no sabía dónde cambiar el dinero
era muy inseguro ir a la calle y por
otro lado era muy caro hacerlo en el
banco nos juntamos se nos prende el foco
y dijimos por qué las casas porque hay
gente que sale con chaleco antibalas y
con billetes en mano a cambiar dinero
era impensable hay que hacer algo
digital una casa de cambio digital en
pleno siglo 21 todavía hay gente con
charlé con chaleco antibalas en la calle
así que lo hicimos rápidamente
ejecutamos hicimos la plataforma nos
juntamos con los socios adecuados y
creamos la primera casa de cambio
digital en el perú se llama campista con
acá hoy en día tenemos 23 personas que
trabajan con nosotros es una empresa
rentable hace dos años hemos abierto
puertas en argentina y curiosamente
hemos seguido fracasando
apenas abrimos tuvimos 10 operaciones el
primer mes en un éxito dijimos 10
operaciones era tan es tan exitoso que
hacíamos planchas cada operación
hoy día ya hacemos 17.000 operaciones al
mes no podemos hacer planchas pero en
esa época muy emocionados hacíamos las
10 planchas el siguiente mes 40 el
tercer mes 247 el cuarto mes nos cierran
las cuentas del banco
se nos cayó el negocio miami volvió a
australia fue a trabajar ok fracasó otra
vez
pero ya había cambiado la aproximación
al fracaso el fracaso es un compañero es
alguien que te es alguien que te
acompaña siempre y es un amigo con el
que tú siempre vas a tener que lidiar
así que fuimos al banco tocamos las
puertas de aquellos gerentes que nos
pueden abrir decimos señores no somos
una casa de cambio normal somos la casa
cambio digital no aceptamos efectivos
por favor ahora nos la cuenta pasaron
tres meses nos abrieron las cuentas y
volvió toda la historia hoy en día hemos
abierto argentina la política argentina
está horrible han puesto un tope mínimo
de 200 dólares al mes y probablemente
vaya a fracasar y pensaremos en el
siguiente
queremos crear distintas distintos
emprendimientos con los mismos socios
para cada problema esta es una casa de
cambio digital hemos creado otra que se
llama paga después que es una plataforma
que te da el préstamo esas personas que
no están bancarizadas para comprar
cualquier cosa en un y commerce y vamos
a entrar en distintos sectores que nos
encantaría poder solucionar
entonces me quedo con tres cosas
importantes
una es que fracasen y fracasen rápido
porque si lo hacen van a aprender estas
tres cosas que le voy a decir
una es que el fracaso no es malo lo que
es malo es lo que te dices a ti mismo
acaso lo que se hace es que te ayuda a
verte a ti mismo y a pararte y a ponerte
frente a la perspectiva de aceptarte
tercero florece en ti lo más creativo e
innovador que nunca se hayan podido
imaginar fracasen y fracasen rápido
muchas gracias
[Música]